wir müssen wir mal zurückkommen auf
diese auf diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und auf die
tatsache warum die so laufen diese
nämlich schlecht vorbereitet in wahrheit
und diese schlechte vorbereitung liegt
auch daran dass aus dem bundeskanzleramt
oder so auch drei stunden vorher oder
narben am späten nachmittag vorher dann
erste beschlussvorlage bedingen an
landesregierungen geschickt werden wo
man sagen muss es am märz 14 tage nicht
darüber gesprochen und dann kommt ganz
irgendwas dabei raus und dann wird man
in der tat darauf solche
findungskommission die dann auch völlig
irre sündige beschlüsse fassen weil
einer der buchhandlungen auch gut findet
sind plötzlich bücher gegenstände des
täglichen lebens bedarfs- und werden am
dritten märz plötzlich mit dazu erklärt
weil irgendeiner sagt jetzt muss aber
über ostern noch richtig was scharfes
passieren entsteht so eine oster ruhe
dieser mpk es müssen anders vorbereitet
werden auch so vorbereitet werden dass
sie im zweifel mit den jeweiligen
kabinetten in den ländern abgestimmt
werden können was beim letzten mal
überhaupt nicht der fall war
da konnte man über das thema oster ruhe
vorher überhaupt nicht reden das war
auch nicht bekannt dass wir mal eben in
die luft geschossen solche dinge sind
einfach vom teufel
deshalb sage ich mal es muss darum gehen
mit vernünftiger vorbereitung diese
dinge voranzutreiben an einer stelle
allerdings das will ich auch ganz
deutlich sagen mit einer notbremse die
beschlossen worden ist kann man umgehen
wir haben in schleswig holstein einen
sogenannten hunderte erlassen da ist
ganz klar dass neben der verordnung gibt
es eine erlassen müssen alle kreise die
über 100 gehen sich mit dem
gesundheitsministerium rückkoppeln und
die entsprechenden maßnahmen vereinbaren
das kann man einfach schlicht und
ergreifend machen führt dazu dass eine
stadt wie flensburg die kurzfristig
deutlich über 100 war dann wieder unter
100 ist heute und dass man das wieder
herunter führt wenn man allerdings in
den ländern dann einfach zukunft und
sagt ja ist dann halt so dass uns jetzt
aber weiterlaufen weil wir uns nicht
trauen
jetzt auch die entsprechende
konsequenten beschlüsse zur da muss man
sich nicht wundern
also in dem land wie schleswig-holstein
mit einer insolvenz von immer noch unter
70 kann man glaube ich allerdings auch
eines sagen ja dieses land hat sich
nicht versteckt hinter irgendeiner
kanzlerin
wir haben nie gesagt dass wir nicht
selber irgendwie unsere beschlüsse
fassen wollten
beim letzten mal er mit dem was wir
machen würden zurückgepfiffen worden
weil wir gesagt haben wir würden gerne
bestimmte dinge auf eine art und weise
mehr akzeptanz schaffen machen da ist
dann die sitzung unterbrochen worden und
wird das will so kann man das nicht
machen also dass länder hier keine
verantwortung übernehmen worden ist
märchen aber vorbereitung ist notwendig